bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france à leur première
question est ce que ces déclarations
vous ont surpris concernant ericsson et
ses supposés pau devant à dice en irak
bonjour moi je trouve que c'est à c'est
un scandale c'est vrai qu'on y est on a
déjà eu l'occasion de voir des affaires
aussi révélatrice on va dire sur sur
cette question de financement de
terrorisme il y avait déjà avant la
sphère de de lafarge qui a fourni une
quinzaine de millions d'euros à l'état
l'état islamique pour soi-disant de la
protection après il y avait là faire
aussi de toyota qui a vendu 25 mille
voitures et des voitures blindées à
l'état islamique et à d'autres groupes
terroristes et bon voilà le nouveau on
va dire ce qu'on peut dire sur cette
question là c'est que le rôle on va dire
des certaines grandes entreprises dans
ce genre de d'opérations de financement
parce qu'avant on s'intéressait à voir
le rôle de certaines ong des états même
que le monde sait parfaitement le rôle
de la turquie le rôle du qatar dans
cette question dans cette affaire en
irak ou en série en menant de
l'approvisionnement et de la fourniture
pour l'état l'état islamique maintenant
ce qui est nouveau c'est le rôle des
grandes entreprises et ce qui manque en
fin de compte c'est le fait de de mettre
en place des des procédures de reddition
des comptes et de d2 et de protection on
va dire financière maintenant le nouveau
dans la sphère érection c'est que c'est
l'entreprise même c'est le pdg qui a
reconnu on va dire tu ce qui s'était
passé parce que avant les autres à faire
c'était un effort purement purement
médiatique par contre je signale qu'ils
aient une absence de du rôle de l'état
on va dire en général des services de
renseignement occidentaux rendre sur
cette question-là de recherche kid
enquête concernant le rôle d des
entreprises dont le financement d'entre
des terroristes alors justement vous
avez parlé
de la sphère lafarge c'était en syrie
qu'elle quelles similitudes entre voilà
ces déclarations aujourd'hui en tout cas
ces révélations concernant ericsson et
lafarge à l'époque est ce que ce sont
deux affaires qui sont identiques ou il
ya des divergences tout de même
jusqu'à maintenant je trouve qu'il ya
pas trop de divergences à part la
question que de dire que lafarge c'est
une affaire quand même des tas parce
qu'il y avait la publication de
certaines institutions étatiques
notamment les services de renseignement
le gouvernant le gouvernement français
d'après les révélations à l'époque de
libération qui ont montré qu'ils étaient
au courant de cette opération
maintenant pour le cas ericsson je
trouve qu'il y aura bien évidemment un
impact économique par la suite sur sur
l'entreprise parce que ça touche une
image la réputation de cette entreprise
et c'est aussi dans six une entreprise
qui travaille dans un secteur clé avec
une grande importance et influent ce
mondial tout ce qui concerne la
technologie le numérique et le mobile en
parle maintenant de la géopolitique du
mobile c'est ont fait le lien entre le
huawei est par exemple et la chine entre
appels et les états unis mais bien
évidemment on sait parfaitement qui à
nokia ou ericsson dans les pays
scandinaves et qui reflète en quelque
sorte le rôle européen dans cette dans
cette technologie et donc effectivement
ces grandes entreprises sur fut du
mobile dépense énormément d'argent sur
le lobbying surtout dans les instances
internationales et les instances
européennes
donc là ce qui pour moi ce qui est clair
c'est qu'il ya déjà un vide juridique
là-dessus concernant la question de la
transparence de la gouvernance de de
fournitures on va dire l d'équipement et
même de financement de certaines
organisations
jihadistes et et terroristes et
deuxièmement c'est le monde des
responsabilités des nations unies parce
que quand même dans des zones de crise
et de et de conflits il n'y a pas d'état
donc il n'y a pas d'institution n'y a
pas de sécurité c'est les nations unies
normalement qui doivent mettre en place
des procédures pour la sécurité et du
fait que les nations unies ne dispose
pas d'un service de renseignement
capable de suivre
de bien sûr de tracé est tous les
mouvements de transaction va
effectivement
les entreprises profitent de cette de
cette situation maintenant ce qui ce
qu'il faut signaler c'est que l'état
islamique n'est pas c'est pas fini arias
est juste question de transformation de
de stratégie et on parle d'une
organisation transfrontalière dans les
effets normalement de crime le se
limitent pas seulement en séries en irak
mais aussi en europe et on se rappelle
bien en france depuis 2015 y avait
énormément d'attentats terroristes au
nom de l'état et cela alors pour revenir
un petit peu à la sphère ericsson donc
on l'a appris dans la presse mercredi
mais on a également appris qu'une
enquête interne avait été mené elle
avait été diligentée par le pdg du
groupe il ya deux ans des sanctions
d'ailleurs ondées ont été prises contre
à certains employés qui étaient
impliqués dans cette affaire est-ce que
c'est peu finalement par rapport à
l'ampleur de cette affaire ce qu'il
faudrait voilà que ça atteignent un
point de vue plus juridique à l'image
peut-être de ce qui s'est passé pour
lafarge en syrie
oui effectivement sur le plan juridique
je suis tout à fait d'accord maintenant
comment ça va en appliquer des sanctions
c'est à dire est-ce que c'est auprès de
l'état irakien parce que c'est celles et
ceux qui sont qui sont concernés ou bien
au niveau ou au niveau européen du fait
qu'on parle d'une entreprise aux
européens ou bien il y aura des
sanctions américains comme c'est le cas
généralement quand les états unis en
fait et les concernés par ce genre
d'affaires on voit directement qu'il ya
des sanctions qui conserve en soit les
comptes bancaires des entreprises ou
même les transactions de cette
entreprise avec les états unis parce
qu'on a quand même assisté à certains à
sa panne éléments concernant par exemple
les sanctions américaines qui ont été
posées contre contre l'iran ou contre la
russie il ya toujours une accusation
adressé assez assez assez entreprises
donc là maintenant là je crois pas qu'au
niveau au niveau légal y aura grand
chose du fait que même c'est
l'entreprise qui a reconnu sa dont il
n'ya pas jusqu'aujourd'hui n'y a pas d'
enquête ayant le dire pas dans le cadre
pénal mais ça montre clairement qu'il ya
qu'il ya un vide là elle est là dessus
et que normalement dès les instances
européennes doivent travailler à
a déjà un ou deux bombes conduite
concernant les pratiques de financement
surtout en temps de tension en
l'occurrence le le moyen orient et par
la suite la reddition des comptes qu'ils
avaient des saisons dernière question
est il possible de chiffrer les l'epo
devant les versements qui ont été
réalisés au profit
de l'organisation état islamique en irak
on avait peut-être voilà évoqué le
chiffre de 13 millions d'euros pour
lafarge en civil
bon pour la queue pour le cas de lafarge
parce qu'il y avait quand même des
documents qui est des nôtres qui a
montré le ce genre de de financement
mais on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
tracer l'ensemble des financements
soient qui viennent de certains états
des ordres de aux ong ou même d des
entreprises ce qui était sûr c'est que
on savait qu'il y avait un budget annuel
pour l'état islamique y avoisiner les 5
milliards de dollars à l'époque et on a
et on a vu cette évolution dans dans la
façon d'organiser les opérations dont
les données dans l'armement que disposer
l'état islamique parce que si on voit la
trajectoire on va dire depuis ce qui
concerne les mouvements djihadistes ya
quand même une évolution entre al qaïda
et il n'est pas l'état islamique c'est
qu'avec l'état islamique y avait plus de
plus d'organisation plus de deux
d'argent pour pour mettre une certaine
structure ayant parlé plus d'une
organisation djihadiste simple mais on
parle de l'état islamique dont il ya le
concept aussi de l'état ça veut dire des
institutions ça veut dire des relations
à l'étranger ça veut dire un réseau fort
et capable d'amener et d'amener de
financement est également une capacité
transfrontalière a circulé pas seulement
au niveau du moyen-orient mais au niveau
ce qu'on peut rappeler on va dire la
globalisation où la mondialisation 2-10
c'était le cas concret avec avec l état
islamique merci beaucoup en tout cas une
belle feinte l'air d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant en relations internationales